ciao a tutti sono valeria ho 14 anni e
sono la più giovane digital champion
d'europa
sono stata nominata da riccardo luna tra
i primi 100 italiani per il comune di
alessandria ad un grande evento che si è
svolto al tempio del riano a roma la mia
storia è iniziata quando come tutti
dovevo preparare la tesina per l'esame
di terza media
mi è stato assegnato a manzoni
ovviamente non mi poteva piacere
e così oltre alle cose classiche la vita
le opere
ho deciso di fare qualcosa in più di
diverso che piace essere anche a me così
la mia idea iniziale era quella di
riscrivere un capitolo dei promessi
sposi come se manzoni fosse stato un
blogger e avesse dovuto ottimizzare se
io al suo posto e così ho chiesto aiuto
a un gruppo facebook di oltre 13mila
iscritti di informatici gli indigeni
digitali che però nessuna risposta dalla
mia idea iniziale però mi hanno dato un
sacco di spunti idee e modi interessanti
per analizzare i promessi sposi senza
annoiarsi troppo a scuola non è stata
accolta come speravo questa mia idea e
non sono uscita con il massimo dei voti
come volevo però come capita spesso
nella vita quando si chiude una porta si
apre un portone
così sono stata invitata al da fabio
lalli alli di kent durante il todi happy
days è il raduno nazionale di creatori
di app lì è stata accolta in modo
davvero diverso nel frattempo
frequentavo il coder dojo a milano che
mi ha aperto veramente un mondo lì ho
scoperto che mi piaceva molto di più è
la parte hardware rispetto alla parte
software
ho visto diversi cose realizzate con
arduino e da piante digitali a robot
così mi piaceva un sacco e ho deciso di
creare anch'io un mio robot questo è il
mio robot
a due motori un sensore di distanza ed è
realizzato con arduino 1 alduino è una
scheda che permette di realizzare un
sacco di cose con attraverso una parte
hardware con sensori e motori e una
parte software con del codice
è in grado di rilevare gli ostacoli ed
evita evitarli
un po come funziona romba l'unica cosa è
che non aspira la polvere però l'ho
creato io
a me piace chiamarlo la mia creazione
chi sono e cosa fanno i digital champion
i digital champions sono degli
ambasciatori digitali
ogni stato europeo ne ha uno che serve
per rendere i propri cittadini più
digitali il di città del vino italiano è
riccardo luna che ha deciso di
moltiplicare il suo impegno nominando un
digital champion e per ogni comune
il suo obiettivo è arrivare a 8000 più
di 8.000 11 tel champion per ogni comune
una cosa fondamentale è che il digital
champion a budget non è retribuito non
ha staff però porta segno grandi
risultati ha tre obiettivi fondamentali
quello di essere una sorta di help desk
per l'amministrazione pubblica nei campi
del digitale e ds di promuovere corsi di
alfabetizzazione digitale dai bambini ai
nonni e aiutare i cittadini in caso di
assenza di banda larga e wi fi e altri
diritti digitali negati
cosa faccio di completamente sono
riuscito a realizzare un mio grande
sogno quello di portare il coder dojo
anche ad alessandria il kotor dolce è un
movimento volontario apolitico e
gratuito che si è sviluppata ormai in
tutto il mondo quell'obiettivo
dell'insegnamento della programmazione e
del codice ai bambini e ragazzi dai 4
fine 17 anni tutto in modo creativo
perché il coder doge non è una scuola e
un posto dove ci si diverte si può
copiare e migliorare collaborare ne ho
io ad alessandria
abbiamo iniziato con la fascia di età
dai 7 14 anni utilizzando scratch
io sono coach ampio perché champion da
sole non potevo essere essendo minorenne
e quindi il tempio in ufficiale luca
parmitano inca pantano con cui mi piace
un sacco collaborare
ho fatto anche un corso sta facendo
anche un corso per i nonni in cui
insegniamo le cose più semplici
computer perché il computer semplifica
davvero tanto la vita anche alle persone
più anziane ea in questo corso
insegniamo a mandare mail utilizzare
skype elaborare foto a utilizzare office
il modo però di apprendimento dei
bambini è completamente diverso da
quello degli adulti infatti i bambini
imparano molto in fretta ci mettono
tantissimo impegno e poi da una volta
dall'altra arrivano ancora più preparati
i nonni invece ci mettono un po di più
imparare ci mettono un pochino meno
impegno ed è una volta a lhasa si
dimenticano proprio tutto
pensate che abbiamo iniziato con skype e
ancora adesso dobbiamo rifare skype
perché non se lo ricordano
ho partecipato anche come speaker a
diversi eventi allo smau con gli altri
digital champion piemontesi ho
raccontato la mia esperienza per
ispirare altri ragazzi anche in alcune
scuole della provincia di alessandria
dove abito e per appassionare alla
tecnologia
ho partecipato ad alcuni talk show
locali come salotto del mandrogno e ho
raccontato la mia esperienza e tutto
quello che faccio anche in radio in
alcune radio locali e nella trasmissione
e tabitha su radiouno in cui ho parlato
di coda dojo oltre a essere original
champion sono anche blogger sono la più
giovane travel blogger d'italia e ho
cominciato a scrivere un po per gioco
quando facevo le elementari
all'inizio raccontavo di parco giochi e
attività per bambini
adesso racconto degli aspetti che mi
colpiscono di più in viaggio di quello
che faccio dal mio punto di vista di
teenager e appassionate di tecnologia
pensate che quando avevo 14 mesi avevo
visto 14 stati ea otto mesi sono andate
in macchina in inverno a capo nord
e così vi potete subito rendere conto in
via famiglia di pazzi sono lata i miei
progetti futuri sono tanti
mi piacerebbe incentivare molto il coder
dojo portandolo anche per i bambini non
ha saputi dati quelli dei quattro ai sei
anni che non sanno leggere e scrivere
utilizza utilizzando scratch e junior
anche su tablet che attraverso
l'utilizzo di forme colori in modo
divertente insegna loro le basi della
programmazione tutto perché serve qui
tutto quello che serve per il loro
futuro mi piacerebbe portare al coder
dojo di alessandria anche la parte
quella che mi piace di più quella
hardware portando arduino e la scheda
mckay mckay di google
la scheda amiki miei che ier
permette l'utilizzo di qualsiasi oggetto
che conduca al posto della tastiera
tutto attraverso l'utilizzo solo di
hardware e senza bisogno di
programmazione sto costruendo una
stampante 3d la frusta i tre che non
vedo l'ora di finire per poterla testare
provare e creare qualche oggetto che mi
piace
tra poco aprirà anche il fab lab
d'alessandria con stampanti 3d laser
cutter fresatrici non vedo dove spero
che sia all'altezza di quello come
quello di milano
il mio ultimo progetto ormai in
dirittura d'arrivo il libro del nostro
blog che tratterà di viaggi per famiglie
low cost in cui anch'io ho scritto
alcuni capi capitoli e che vi è che
racconto del difficile rapporto che c'è
tra viaggi e scuola e come riescono
nonostante le tantissime assenze per i
viaggi a essere tra i migliori della
classe e grazie all'utilizzo di internet
che mi permette di capire gli argomenti
che stanno facendo
seguendo facendo delle lezioni online
viaggiando ho scoperto che in giro per
il mondo ci sono gli altri teenager
vivono in modo molto diverso da come
vivo io per esempio sono andati in posti
tipo il nepal lo sri lanka e li loro non
con non sanno niente di cosa c'è al di
fuori del loro paese l'unico loro mezzo
per conoscere il mondo è quello di
utilizzare facebook quelle quando cioè
la connessione e poi quando arriva
qualche turista gli chiedono qualsiasi
cosa perché sono proprio curiosi di
sapere quello che quello che fai
pensate che una ragazzina della mia età
in nepal
ma persino chiesto a che casta
appartengo e non ci credeva che in
italia non esistessero le caste e poi
sono stato fatto tantissimi viaggi
quello che quello che invece di più e
viaggiare negli stati uniti dall'anno
scorso che li ho scoperti mi sono
piaciuti un sacco andando
in florida mi piacerebbe poi andare in
california per andare nella silicon
valley e vedere tutti quei mega uffici
che ci sono
grazie a tutti per l'attenzione